allez bon chacun dans la cantine
american louis deuxième chance qui s'y
tiennent
quant à la question des médicaments des
lycées de la camionnette un mandat émis
avec elle en vain
[Musique]
chacun dans la gamme et reagan
miam
m
ce week-end à anglet oui
le mexique 1.626 cas pas
[Musique]
fabien taillefer aux huit mois
ouais
[Musique]
mexicain battra tête
allongé sur le sol
sombrero sur le net en guise en d1 sorti
un guide
[Musique]
il n'est pas loin de mille îles après le
soleil
c'est formidable aujourd'hui ce que j'y
serai
est ce qu'ils sont c'est un problème à
n'en plus finir chaque jour chaque nuit
c'est l'eau mais il vaut mieux dormir
[Musique]
deux premiers à manger ce n'est pourtant
là qu'un détail mais ça suffirait t'a
poussé un homme autres gagnent
[Musique]
actionnaires ils ont réprouvé un cas
pour jouer un verre en trois coups de
dés je ne vois ça n'est pas chez tout
nouvellement et d'ailleurs ils sont les
modifier
aussi bien que moi
dans sa logique à malibu et mark webber
se vengerait voudront s'il devait
pleuvoir
un mexicain basse allaine
d'allonger sur le sauveur
sombrero sur le net en dix ans guy en
guise en guise en vie un but venu samedi
en guise de parasol ou oui oui toi aussi
venir cristobal monde qui les fuyait
c'est vrai qu'il est générale que depuis
juillet
tant qu'il aura terminé cette évolution
continue et les deux la conversation est
mon meilleur ami j'ai parié sur lui ni
pesos et si les vaches du jeu n'est plus
qu'à leur dire adieu
on voit partout des soldats courant dans
les rues si vous ne vous gardez pas il
m'a reçu
et le matin quel boucan ce que nous
venons ce qu'ils sont ignorants agaçant
avec leur canon
ça n'arrête pas dire mieux fut pareil à
midi
quand il est dit dans ce brillant dans
son véhicule un mexicain basané
et
[Musique]
sombrero sur monnet
en guise en guise en guise sanguine
qu'elle est couché à l'écouté de monaco
1 1
[Musique]
haruhi
puis-je ce deux phases
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]